el activista joshua von ha sido
condenado hoy a 13 meses y medio de
cárcel por incitar yo organizar una
asamblea ilegal otros los compañeros han
sido condenados a diez y siete meses son
penas relativamente bajas porque la ley
prevé incluso cinco años a los
activistas les ha beneficiado por un
lado que se declararan culpables antes
del juicio y por otro que los hechos
ocurrieran antes de la entrada en vigor
de la ley de seguridad nacional que
prevé incluso la cadena perpetua los
tres activistas han sido condenados por
su participación en el asedio a una
comisaría de wanchai el verano pasado
esos asedios fueron habituales durante
los siete meses de protestas que
asolaron hong kong durante el año pasado
y que incluían el lanzamiento de piedras
las pintadas o incluso las pequeñas
hogueras a las puertas de las comisarías
wong a pesar de sus 24 años es un viejo
conocido en la escena activista de hong
kong empezó ya como adolescente en
causas sociales después vino a la
política y labró su reputación durante
la revuelta de las paraguas
y micrófono en mano arengaba las masas
ha pasado ya tres veces por la cárcel y
simboliza la polarización de la sociedad
para unos es un luchador indesmayable
por la libertad para otros es un agente
al servicio de las fuerzas extranjeras
que quieren desestabilizar hong kong y
no le perdonan que nunca haya condenado
ni siquiera a los actos más violentos
cometidos por los manifestantes